okay people today we're gonna be looking
at SCP 407 object class neutralized
special containment procedures at time
of acquisition SCP 407 was recorded
within a compact cassette tape currently
SCP 407 is backed up as a digital audio
file on SCP 407 should not be allowed to
play under any circumstances outside
testing conditions and only with the
approval of a 5 testing of SCP 407 is to
be done in completely soundproof
environments all tools and subjects must
be sterilized to remove the presence of
pollen fungal spores plant seeds and as
much bacterial life to the greatest
degree possible to delay the negative
effects of SCP 407 description SCP 407
is a song in an unidentified language
seemingly sung a cappella the voices are
thought to be human the tape containing
SCP 407 was found with one track of
approximately 30 minutes duration though
the abrupt ending suggests there may be
more the song has been described by all
listeners as something along the lines
of soothing glorious and beautiful while
SCP 407 is played rapid cell generation
seems to occur with an auditory radius
this effect seems to occur at the
cellular level and does not require the
subject to be able to hear the music the
changes seem to only affect
multicellular organisms at first but
quickly begins to affect mitosis and
single-cell organisms during the first
minute of exposure all multicellular
life forms seemed to become healthier
subjects suffering from malnutrition
scarring physical injury or chronic
diseases or other medical conditions
seemed to become healthy with only a
minute of exposure to SCP 407 this has
been shown to cure Alzheimer's disease
Crohn's disease brain and spinal cord
injuries and normally fatal infections
or wounds amongst other things
interestingly cancer does not seem to be
affected though the subjects physical
condition was still vastly improved
during the second and third minute of
exposure subjects start experiencing
unnecessarily unrestrained cell growth
manifesting in quickly advancing dermal
growths these growths seem to mostly be
benign tumors and calcium and fat
deposits which though sometimes painful
and disfiguring are not life-threatening
during the fourth minute of exposure
increased bacterial and fungal growth
occurs creating conditions that grow
increasingly dangerous for all exposed
life even in their new healthier States
respiratory and digestive problems are
quick to arrive in most cases and become
steadily worse as time progresses past
five minutes the effects of SCP 4:07
seem to differ each trial in all cases
trace elements of plants or fungus as
well as any animal life present begin to
grow and replicate uncontrollably at
varying rates often shaping into new
organisms full results have varied
depending on the test and on the objects
present when ICP 407 is played this is
addendum 407 - 0 1 SCP 407 was found in
the home of Professor of who had
recently returned from research in the
Amazon regions of northern Brazil agents
were first alerted to a possible as EP
went
this is addendum 407 - 0 - the mold that
eventually resulted from SCP 407 second
test seems to be some sort of cordyceps
fungi noted to be similar to mold
encountered by SCP 507 due to the fear
of fulfilling a fate similar to that
observed by 507 testing using SCP 407
has been limited to only using the first
20 minutes of recording
and this is a denim 407 - 3 this is a
sample test run of SCP 407 for full
research and experimentation notes see
experiment log 407 sample test notes
test - SCP 407 played for 28 minutes and
32 seconds within chamber 1 d-class
personnel unsterilized 25 seconds
subject reports feeling soothed by the
music and of feeling stronger and more
invigorated 45 seconds liver spots and
scars previously seen are shown to
disappear 2 minutes 20 subject appears
to have physically grown an inch
increase in musculature is noticeable 3
minutes 40 subject reports intestinal
pain 4 minutes 20 subject begins
vomiting from vomit plants are seeing
growing and slowly rooting into the tile
floor
four minutes fifty subject starts
developing rashes and growths on skin
five minutes thirty heavy dermal
disfigurement subject panting heavily
begging for help
great pain reported six minutes ten
subject falls to ground and ceases to
move six minutes forty five subjects
body is quickly covered in what is
thought to be fungal infections plant
growth is observed to be growing from
the subjects mouth then eye sockets
seven minutes thirty subject is by this
time unrecognizable covered in molds and
plant shoots body bursts as a banana
tree emerges from the subjects
intestines and proceeds to grow to
maturity within seconds eight minutes
forty five plant and fungal growth has
begun to spread throughout the testing
chamber what appears to be moss and
weeds cover the floor nine minutes
thirty several shoots stalks bushes and
even small trees have appeared banana
tree is no longer recognizable the trees
grown thick and is covered with foliage
and fungal growth ten minutes thirty
there is heavy with pollen and spores
vision into testing chamber is difficult
eleven minutes thirty movement is heard
within the chamber several different
small insect-like creatures are observed
creatures are a seemingly made of plant
matter
17 minutes 34 the last six minutes
creatures made of plant matter have been
observed to rapidly regenerate grow to
maturity kill and eat other creatures
and then be eaten themselves creatures
increasingly progressing in size his
time increases 19 minutes medium-sized
mammalian creatures are observed they
seem humanoid and bear a resemblance to
initial subject 21 minutes large fungal
stalk is observed to grow from one of
the mammalian creatures stalk and bursts
dispensing white spores 22 minutes plant
growth is still lush but everything
begins to become coated by a layer of
mold the plant creatures seem to die
slowly for an unknown reason before
being covered by the mold 23 minutes
mammalian creatures are the last to
succumb then heavily decay and become
covered in the same mold bodies are
shown to contract and expand as if
breathing stalks quickly rise from the
bodies burst with spores and then just
as quickly rot 28 minutes 32 tape ends
no change in chamber since the
appearance of the mold chamber undergoes
rigorous anti biological cleansing
samples of the mold were taken and tests
this is addendum 407 - four
SCP 407 has been deleted from the system
by what is now known to the foundation
as the interest group Serpent's hand all
known backup copies of SCP 407 have also
been deleted refer to incident report
x-23
this is security breach incident x-23 on
the SCP site 19 breached by operatives
from an organization known to the
foundation only as the Serpent's hand
site 19 breach the breach of site 19
seems to have been the second of two
break-ins in two SCP properties but note
the foundation is LS this individual is
responsible for a previous security
breach
having coordinated the theft of scp-261
from video surveillance that scp-261
involved in this infiltration the
intruder known as LS seems to have
simply walked into site 19 the intrusion
seems to have been for the purpose of
using scp-914 knowledge of the intruders
use of scp-914 can only be assumed due
to the intruders interruption of doctor
during routine testing doctor seems to
have been resulting in the intrusions
only personnel casualty SCP 407 seems to
have been deleted from the foundation
system during this time so it can only
be assumed that the individuals involved
are responsible whether this means the
file has been completely destroyed or
possibly in the hands of a rogue group
is unknown a short printed note was
found in scp-914 chamber this note is
the only insight the foundation
currently has of the group responsible
for this incident see document X 23 - 0
1
dear Sirs of the foundation behind the
guns and protocol you hide desperately
chaining the ineffable yourselves stuck
within your own self rot pitiful cages
of fear and ignorance you think
yourselves the Shepherd guarding the
flocks of the unwise or the night but he
were so shaken by doubt and fear that in
Europe bewildered arrogance he would
vainly seek to chain the Sun itself unto
the heavens to hold back the daily night
the delivering angels themselves you
contain with three digits and four walls
do you not see the blindness with which
you walk and swing your blade on the
final day would you have us contain
black suitor himself with measures and
science and condemn ourselves to rotten
stagnancy as you hold back it's pure
cleansing fires I do not ask you to act
but act with enlightenment and harp
neither should one be seduced by the
dark nor blinded by the light but walk
firmly in the Twilight and gaze onto all
realms walk the world of fire with bare
feet and you will find yourself without
the scars you never knew you had I leave
you with one final truth the garden is
the Serpent's place the divinities of
fear and order who come to walk in the
cool evening air are only visitors do
not fail to see the evil hiding in the
light nor the aromatic beauty of the
palest flower of Darkness signed
sincerely LS PS you'll thank me for
deleting what you call 407
this was SCP 407 ending transmission